ok eccolo l'unica cosa è un gioco che
parte subito è fatto è fatto in modo
penso amatoriale però è fatto veramente
bene nel senso che fa più paura di
amnesia ragazzi per quello che ho
giocato io per quei due minuti poi non
ce l'ho fatta più
perché fa veramente il prezzo non è che
personalmente una pensione a livelli
estremi amnesia veramente non è nulla in
confronto a questo in quanto mette in
tensione
quindi ragazzi io non so cosa mi troverò
davanti ma spero veramente che vada
tutto bene perché si rischia li fa
buongiorno ok
collect eight bass allora ragazzi la
cosa che penso si debba fare in questo
gioco per quanto ho capito è raccogliere
delle pagine di un diario non so le
pagine comunque che sono in totale otto
sono sparse per questa foresta e nappa
io sono arrivato fino a qui lo vedete
voi adesso poi aspetto perché già questo
mi mette tensione tantissimo perché
neanche amnesia riesce ad avere un
ambientazione così spaventoso perché
vedete nella foresta fittissima al buio
è veramente assurdo poi ogni tanto
sempre normalissima
ok si corre con shift è sì insomma con
cui sincero nei comandi nella cartella
di gioco e poi niente si spegne in si
accende la luce intatta cosa quella roba
lì
e qui i ragazzi mi giro sempre per
questa veramente assurdo matrangola una
statua nega dildo
bello una pagina che interno anni non
puoi correre
sì che possa cosa c'è sì cazzo dici
ho sentite anche voi sento dei tamburi
tipo no ragazzi su questo è veramente io
sono al buio in stanza mummia centro
nord
non posso perché se no devo staccare il
pc e non senta io sento figlio hanbury
sempre più frequenti no oddio quando si
va ragazzi e attenzione veramente
assurda nel suo gioco c'è veramente non
e acam mesi poi livello che io sto
cercando di parlare perché quando io
parlo un po mi rilasso nel senso che
sembra di essere in compagnia quindi
diminuisco un po l'attenzione ma
migliore assurdo comunque provatelo
perché tanto c'è un fritz j e amatoriale
non è un politico per chi ce la fa a
reggere nel caso fate finta di parlare
con qualcuno mi sto facendo io anche se
vi state ascoltando vai mai
indirettamente a sono io che il corso
ok ma ci sono altre rocce un fantastico
la luce ma non si scarica o leave me
alone il cazzo ti caga ok siamo a due
ragazzi io non so se lo dividerà in
episodi perché non ho idea di quanto ci
metto a raccoglierle tutte penso che lo
scopo del gioco sia soltanto questo
soltanto veramente messo tra virgolette
è però non sta succedendo niente cioè mi
sto preoccupando per nulla ok ragazzi
non è da lì che cosa succederà quando si
raccoglieranno comunque ragazzi in
questo momento che sa
che cazzo ma c'è chi cazzo è quello
chi cazzo è mattia specchi và
interferenza sta roba quando lo guardo
ma lo vedete anche voi
oddio di oddio di odio non ho mai
interferenza ma l'addio via il resto si
avvicinava ma chi cazzo è no ma assurdo
[ __ ] ma che cazzo ti vuole roma
via ma chi è
lavorate o ma che cazzo lo sono già i
pedofili qui ho un altro partito
bella questa
le scritte erano molto utili ok no no no
no no però ragazzi i nostri rumori no no
no va bene il tipo e tutto finché sta lì
lontano io mi pio qualche colpo ma da
lontano ancora bene ma piano e poi con
gli effetti sonori che sono pesanti
processo
cazzo
c'è un tunnel
sono quattro ragazzi don't look orit
takes you o mi prenderà non lo guardare
e io l'ho guardato prima non lo sono
scappato in chiaro porca put
ma cosa min che è successo ragazzi no ma
sono ripartito da zero ma vabbè
ascoltate non è possibile allora
praticamente ho premuto allora se uscito
da quel tunnel ho premuto il tasto est
permettere tipo in pausa perché mi
chiami sono pilato un infarto e mi si è
spento il gioco cioè praticamente questo
sai che ti esce il gioco dal gioco
proprio è praticamente ho letto che quel
tipo ii perché ho dato cioè prima di
adesso lo riavviato brevemente subito
sono passati due minuti la prima ho
soltanto detto che se lo guardi negli
occhi ti si spegne al gioco devi
iniziare trova di tanto quindi quando va
interferenza se premier che ti esce dal
gioco
proprio per caos poi non assi ma restare
soffrendo in silenzio al forno dicevo se
premier che ti esce dal gioco proprio
interamente ed è una reazione spontanea
nel senso che l'hanno fatto apposta
perché ogni volta i tipi un colpo ti
viene da premere esche e quindi il gioco
si spegne e te lo devi fare e ci sono
cascato in pieno
no no ma c'è boh non lo so ma quello che
è successo veramente assurdo
cioè non possono fare i giochi così va
bene che fa paura però dai eccessivo un
po di contegno ragazzi non possono farsi
cosa c'è veramente assurdo sono uscito
da lì mi sono trovato quello in faccia
mi chiami sono pia che un infarto ha
lanciato il mouse la sedia e tutto il
resto
roba lì
nova [ __ ] vattene via non ti voglio più
vedere pezzente che non sei altro che se
mi chiami arrivi davanti di nuovo non ci
sono il tipo dei bastoni da tirali in
testa perché mi chiama
mi ha preso troppo male prima ma c'è un
camion che cazzo mi rappresenta un cane
se riesco a trovare le chiavi ti investo
e non me ne sbatte niente non c'è niente
presentato a fan culo ma howard e non
c'è più
questo è il bel parco chi cazzo sei ok
non devo guardare solo miseria via il
gioco cioè mi si spegne si avvicina sto
bastardo poi sparito io sempre paura
girarmi non senso mi mettevi mi appare
davanti di un colpo che c'è un edificio
quando in scienze di ragazzi cazzo
terra terriccio no vabbè comunque
ragazze prima avevo consigliato adesso
dello sconsiglio ormai iniziato
purtroppo con evitare figure di merda
devo finirlo ma poi iniziate se non
volete morire giovani ok c'è niente
paura ritorno avanti a non parlare che
schifo e o cystic sto tamburo e mi dà un
fastidio non c'è niente arriva e fa ci
sono già stato non c'è niente valente
che cazzo se avesse posto
lo hanno fatto ma non serve a niente è
in una situazione difficile inutile
non penso ci sarà una pagina nascosta
non ci posso credere che cazzo serve
sono qui non ci sono ancora andato ma è
aperto sto a fare il giro qui posto ok
io voglio posso video che mi vado a
vedere come quello stato qual è stata la
reazione di il wifi perché l'ha fatto
non ho voluto vedere appunto perché se
non ha senso però voglio vedere dello
stato io l'unico che si è cagato addosso
così comunque qua dentro non c'è niente
sarà strano perché
c'è un edificio norme non c'è nulla
vabbè comunque non penso di fare tutti
questo episodio e direi di direi di
dividerlo dividono in più o cristo
[ __ ] è ancora lì mano è possibile non
giocatelo ragazzi non so se ci tenete a
voi stessi non giocate lo guarda l'io
non c'è più poi sparito
i boiler io non toccherò mai più
sto gioco dopo aver fatto e come entry
amnesia la spodestato di violenza
protesta rosa followers segue
ah sì non l'avevo notato grazie lo stato
utile soci
ok ragazzi io corro come la nato perché
paura né 80 poi sembra che ogni pagina
che prendo quello di si manifesta in
modo più cioè si manifesti più quindi
prima
trovo le pagine tutte prima finisco sta
roba dove ritrovare il posto di prima
dove poi ho spento e coleman meglio di
idoli guarda riguarda mourinho